we're now ready for Newton's third law
of motion and something once again
you've probably heard it people talk
about but in this video I want to make
sure we really understand what Newton is
talking about when he says this is a
this is a translation of the Latin
version of it to every action there is
always and just so you clear Newton was
English but he wrote it in Latin because
at that point in time people wrote in
things in Latin because it was viewed as
a more serious language but anyway to
every action there is always an equal
and opposite reaction or the forces of
two bodies on each other are always
equal and are directed in opposite
directions so what Newton is saying is
that you can't just have a force acting
on some object without that object also
having an opposite force acting on the
thing that's trying to act on it and
just to make it clear let's say that we
have a and we'll talk about these
examples in a second let's say that I
have a some type of block right over
here and that I move and I press on the
block and I try to push it forward so
this is my hand this is my hand trying
to trying to press on the block and
exert a force a net force in that
direction so that the block moves to the
right maybe we maybe this block is
sitting on some type of ice so that it
can move so let's say that I have some
that doesn't look like ice even more ice
like color so the block is sitting on
maybe some ice like that so Newton's
third law saying look I can press on
this block and sure I'll exert a net
force on this block and that net force
will accelerate the block assuming that
I can overcome friction and if it's on
ice I can do that but that block is
going to exert an equal and opposite
force on me an equal and opposite force
on me and for direct evidence this is
something even though it might not be so
intuitive when it said this equal and
opposite force but direct evidence
that's it's exerting an equal and
opposite force is that my hand will get
compressed I could actually feel the
block exerting pressure on me take your
hand right now and push it against your
desk or whatever you
nearby and you are clearly exerting a
force on the desk so let me let me draw
so let's say I have a desk right here
and if I if I try to push on the desk so
once again this is my these are my
that's my hand right here pushing on the
desk if I push on the desk and I'm
actually doing it right now while I
record this video you'll see so I'm
clearly exerting a force on the desk if
I do it hard enough I might even get the
desk to shake or tilt a little bit and
I'm actually doing that right now but
the same time you'll see that your hand
is getting compressed the palm of your
hand is being pressed down and that's
because the desk is exerting an equal
and opposite force on you if it wasn't
you actually wouldn't even feel it
because you wouldn't even feel the
pressure it would feel your hand would
be completely uncompressed another
example of that say you're walking in
the beach say you're walking on the
beach and you have some sand right here
if you were to step on the sand so let's
say that this is your shoe do my best
attempt to draw a shoe so this is the
shoe if you were to step on the sand
clearly you are exerting a force on the
sand you are exerting a force on the
sand the force that you're exerting on
the sand is the force of your weight the
gravitational attraction between you and
the earth you are exerting that on the
sand the sand is also and another
evidence of that is that the sand is
going to be displaced you're going to
create a footprint the sand is going to
move out of the way because it's being
pushed down so hard so clearly you are
exerting a force on the sand but the
sand is also exerting an equal and
opposite force on you is also exerting
an equal and opposite force on you and
what's the evidence of that well if you
believe if you believe if you believe
Newton's second law if you have this
gravitational force on you you you
should be accelerating downwards unless
there is some other force that balances
it out and the force that balances it
out is the force that the beach or the
sand is exerting on you upwards and so
when you when you net them out there is
a zero net force on you and that's why
you get to stay there while you don't
start
raining down towards the center of the
earth other examples of this this is
maybe the most famous example of
Newton's third law is just how Rockets
work when you're at a rocket either you
know trying to escape the atmosphere or
maybe you're in space there's nothing to
push off of nothing to push off that let
you that let you accelerate so what you
do is you keep stuff to push off in your
fuel tanks and when you allow the proper
chemical reactions or the proper
combustion to take place what it does is
it expels gases at ultra-high velocities
out the back of your rockets and each of
those particles you're exerting a force
on them enough force even though there's
they're super small mass for each one
they're going at super high velocity so
they're being accelerated tremendously
so there's an equal and opposite force
on the rocket the thing that is actually
expelling expelling the gas and so
that's what allows a rocket to
accelerate even when there's nothing in
this directing city to push off of it
just expels
a bunch of things that it or it
accelerates a bunch of things that a
super fast rating put exerts a force on
all these particles and that allows an
equal and opposite force to accelerate
the rocket ahead and another example of
this is if you ever find yourself
drifting in space and this is actually
useful example so that you don't end up
drifting in space forever let's say we
don't ever want this to happen this
astronaut by some chance he loses his
connection to this this little tool arm
right here on the Space Shuttle and he
starts he starts drifting away he starts
drifting away what can that astronaut do
to change the direction of his motion so
that he drifts back to the Space Shuttle
well you look around you're like well
there's nothing to push off of he
doesn't have any wall to push off of it
let's just assume he doesn't have any
rocket Jets or anything like that what
could he do well the one thing you could
do and this is the situation if you're
ever drifting in space is you should
find the heaviest or I should say the
most massive thing on you and we'll
explain the difference between between
mass and weight in a future video but
you should find the most massive thing
that you can carry that you can take off
of you that you can throw and you should
throw in a direction
opposite yourself so let me put it this
way if I throw let's say I'm in space
and I'm floating I'll just shoot I'll
make it look like the glove of a so
let's say that this is this is the glove
of the astronaut there you go that's his
hand
that's the astronauts hand right over
here and let's say he finds some piece
of equipment on his or she finds some
piece of equipment on them that they can
throw they can take off of their to
their tool set and then they could find
the most massive object that they can
throw so what's going to happen is for
some period of time while they push this
object away they will be exerting a
force on that object they will be
exerting a force on that object for some
period of time while they have contact
with the object and that entire time
that object while it is accelerating
while it you are I'll the astronaut
exerting a force on it will be exerting
an equal and opposite force on the hand
of the astronaut or on the astronaut
itself so the object will accelerate in
that direction
and while the astronaut is pushing the
astronaut will accelerate will
accelerate in this direction so what you
do is you throw in the opposite
direction and that allowed the astronaut
to accelerate towards the space shuttle
and hopefully grab on to something